[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
mein leckeres rezept für küsse das ist
türkischer bulgur salat
der salat besteht hauptsächlich aus fein
bull cola weizen und wird aber mit einem
richtig leckeren dressing getoppt und es
wird ganz viel gemüse untergehoben
[Musik]
für unser christel benötigen wir feinen
ball es ist ganz wichtig dass der feind
ist ein paar mehr tipps beim kauf
schreibe ich euch in die infobox das ist
auch ganz wichtig wie viel bock und ihr
im vergleich zur wassermenge hab ich
habe es für euch in gramm abgemessen und
auch noch mal die infobox geschrieben
desweiteren benötigen wir eisbergs
salatgurken petersilie
frühlingszwiebeln außerdem tomaten und
zitronen olivenöl tomatenmark und
paprika mark zum würzen noch salz und
ganz wichtig ist auch granatapfel sehr
ob
nun bereiten wir zuallererst den ball
gut zu und geben den zusammen mit dem
salz in eine ausreichend große schüssel
nun wird das gut umgerührt damit auch
der burg und gleichmäßig gesalzen ist
und wir geben das kochende wasser mit
hinzu ich habe es mir hier nochmal
frischauf gekocht damit es auch wirklich
heiß ist gebe das über dem burgund und
verteile das gut
[Musik]
sobald das wasser mit dem buckel gut
verrührt wurde geben wir in passenden
deckel darüber oder in meinem fall einen
teller und lassen es ganz um mindestens
10 minuten quellen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit geht es weiter mit
der fleißarbeit jetzt wird das gemüse in
feine dünne stücke geschnitten
[Musik]
für mich persönlich gehören zum küste
immer ganz feine und kleine gemüse
scheiben deshalb schneide ich tomaten
gurken und co immer so fein wie möglich
[Musik]
wer übrigens bestimmte gemüsesorten die
petersilie oder frühlingszwiebeln nicht
mag der kann das auch ganz einfach
weglassen oder durch andere gemüsesorten
ersetzen
[Musik]
zu meinem kissen rezept gehören
frühlingszwiebeln einige nehmen auch die
ganz normal zwiebeln oder die roten ich
finde das persönlich mit den
frühlingszwiebeln am besten aber auch
hier gilt dass ihr total variabel sein
könnte und das nimmt was euch am besten
gefällt
[Musik]
das gemüse ist soweit vorbereitet und
kann jetzt erstmal an die seite gelegt
werden nun zeige ich euch wie wir das
dressing zubereiten hierfür nehme ich
mir zuallererst meine zitrone und
prestin saft aus
[Musik]
nachdem der zitronensaft komplett aus
gepresst wurde geben wir das olivenöl
und den granatapfel sirup mit hinzu bei
den zutaten rate ich euch sie nicht
auszutauschen in diesem sehr wichtig für
den geschmack olivenöl hat noch mal
einen richtig leckeren geschmack und
granatapfel sirup ist unverzichtbar bei
christel
[Musik]
nachdem das dann gut verrührt wurde
geben wir das an die seite und machen
weiter mit unserem aufgequollenen burg
[Musik]
ich locker den bürger jetzt noch ein
wenig mit meinem löffel auf und dann
geht es weiter mit unserem tomaten und
paprika mag
[Musik]
nun arbeiten wir mit unserem sauberen
händen weiter und vermengen buckel mit
tomaten und paprika mark und das
funktioniert am allerbesten indem ihr
das zwischen den händen aneinander reibt
und färbt sich das ganze automatisch in
diese schöne rote farbe
sobald dann der ball wohl fertig
vorbereitet wurde geben wir unser vor
geschnittenes gemüse mit hinzu und
führen das gut unter
[Musik]
zu guter letzt macht das dressing
hinzufügen und auch sehr gut miteinander
verrühren und dann ist unser christel
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
ihr seht also mit etwas fleiß arbeit
habt ihr ganz einfach leckeres gesundes
und frisches christus selber hergestellt
falls ihr jetzt auch lust habt küssel
herzustellen dann schaut mal unten in
die infobox ich habe für euch alle
genauen mengenangaben zutaten
aufgeschrieben und außerdem freue ich
mich über eure fotos auf instagram mit
dem hashtag ekis kitchen
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert damit ihr auch nichts
mehr verpasst und ich sagt bis zum
nächsten mal auf die hieß kitchen
[Musik]